Oh my God, Brie,
you dyed your hair.
It looks amazing.
Oh no,
you're just being nice.
No, seriously,
it looks great.
No, I tried to look like Kate
Hudson, but ended up looking
like a golden retriever's
dingleberry.
But you, look at
your cute little dress!
Little?
I'm like a size 100 now.
Anyway, I paid like
$2 for it.
It's probably made out of
old Burger King crowns.
I look like a whore
locked out of her apartment.
( Amy )
Hi!
Amy!
Hey!
I love your hat.
Are you drunk?
I look like
an Armenian man.
People are trying to
buy carpets from me.
Excuse me, when did you start
working for NASA?
You're weightless.
Fuck you,
I'm a fucking cow.
Indian people are trying
to worship me.
I sleep standing
up in a field.
Fancy meeting
you girls here.
Hey!
Of course,
I see everyone
when I look like
Susan Boyle's toothbrush.
You look so pretty.
Uh, Miss Jessica, congrats on
your big promotion, beyotch.
I'm gonna get fired in,
like, two seconds.
No.
I'm legally retarded.
On my SATs, I just drew
a picture of a house
on the first page
and ate the rest.
Lindsay!
Congratulations!
Please, come on, guys.
The father's anybody's guess
and I'm 1,000 years old.
I mean, I bet this thing
is gonna fall out
and be an old cobweb.
You are gonna be
the best mom ever.
I just want to, like,
crawl in your pussy
and have you
give birth to me.
Good luck trying to nurse
on this shriveled-up
spaghetti squash, ugh.
Your tits make Katy Perry's
look like the Holocaust.
That's so true.
They do.
Perky.
Is that Amanda?
Amanda!
Hi!
Hey!
( all )
I love your jacket!
Thank you.
♪♪
( screaming )
( man )
Oh my God!
Oh no!
Watch out!
( glass shattering )
( woman screaming )
( phone alert )
Yay, one new
Twitter follower!